[Music]
look at this right angled triangle ABC
using this information can you find the
length of these two sides yes say we
first want to find the length of this
sides its opposite to this angle and we
know the length of the hypotenuse as
well angle opposite side by fortunate
does this ring a bell
correct we can use the sine functions
here for an angle theta the value of
this function gives us this ratio for a
triangle it is side opposite to angle
theta over the hypotenuse so here we
will have sine 30 is equal to opposite
side BC over the hypotenuse ac
with this we can easily find the length
of side BC
now what about the length of side a B
for this we can use the cosine
trigonometric function for an angle
theta cos theta is equal to the adjacent
side a B over the hypotenuse AC solving
it further would give us the length of
side a be easily earlier we've seen many
trigonometric functions and how useful
they are they can be used for measuring
the heights of buildings or mountains
even sound which travels in the form of
waves can be represented as a
combination of sine and cosine waves
notice that in most cases we've looked
at we know the measure of an angle and a
side and we need to find the measure of
another side but in some situations we
know the ratio of two sides in a
triangle and need to find the measure of
an angle
one example is where the architects use
it to calculate the slope of roofs of
bungalows let me give you another
practical example suppose our friend
Zeki who is 2 meters tall is standing at
a distance of 10 meters from a wall
which is 12 meters tall what would be
the angle of elevation from Zeki to the
top of the wall since zeg is height is 2
meters and the height of the wall is 12
meters this length will be 10 meters
related to these sites we know the
trigonometric tangent function tan theta
is the ratio opposite over adjacent now
we know the value of this ratio and we
want to find the angle theta so the
situation is reversed now so sometimes
in trigonometry we need functions in
which we put the value of the ratio as
an input and get the corresponding
values of the angle as an output what we
need here is the measure of the angle
theta mathematically it's equal to tan
inverse of 1
what are such functions called that's
correct they are called inverse
functions don't really focus on what
this means we will have a deeper look in
the upcoming sessions do subscribe to
our channel to get updated when we
release our next video
[Music]
you